just waiting for the prime opportunity
to push up here players falling got you
know why boy their zero here we go some
door small action here we go folks
doors B starts to get interesting this
was it scary
Darth Maul will excel in phase 2 and
phase 3 action inside I mean he's a
great mobile attacker he's gonna sit
there with his ass through those
quarters - oh absolutely I mean some of
his abilities you can see here he's got
that squid attack he's able to who just
rush in and out of combat and just take
eyes out the process was funny I was
talking to himself earlier and he was
using Darth Maul and he was saying how
there's Boba Fett as well he was talking
about how he wishes Darth Maul pretty
reflect it was like if he can reflect oh
that was a good flanked by Boba Fett
balls shredded the clone army
unfortunately attached to a specialist
now so now everyone's gonna have any
Crips although what's really fun in the
original battles right but I'm gonna be
excited that happened a jump shooter in
shrinky I mean I know people we love
those people lot of people love to jump
at om you've got Ray oh well I I'm super
excited to play as her she's a quite a
powerful character Ross I'm sure you
know she got out of that one really
don't run quickly but oh they got her
enjoyed fallen by a finisher Roy mistake
nobo ray hasn't Sarah hi my name's Shane
hello absolutely so Ray's mind trick is
something that against all enemies will
be confused for a little bit your
controls will kind of you know work
against you they're super close quarters
do you have any likes for the strategies
that you would add
absolutely I'm just isn't if you're the
cones you're hoping that oh jeez I'm so
let's just get torn up this is gonna be
trouble
it's like too soon man I can relive
force awakens again you know like don't
do it
Darth Maul is just destroying absolutely
every
any tips like taking him down I mean you
want to have a try to combine darks fire
[Music]